put like a little this is bad I
shouldn't be telling you guys this hi
I'm Dan I was an adjunct professor in
film and art at a liberal arts college
hi my name is Salani Thomas and I was a
science teacher for a 1st through 5th
grade my name is Jenny I have been
teaching for almost 10 years now all in
preschool today I'm gonna be sharing
some insider knowledge about schooling
Oh what kind of gossip and the teachers
lounge we talk about everything I don't
want to get myself in trouble here it's
nothing that I think a student would
find terribly interesting it's all about
like unionization when we're taking
vacations if we're even gonna be able to
afford a vacation talking to it about
the administration a little bit mainly I
think we just talk about who's bugging
who talk about our co-workers I guess we
do talk about you for sure most of the
time we talk about our experiences if we
deal with really bad or misbehave
children because if you're a problem to
one teacher we want to know if you're a
problem to every teacher or if you just
hate us or if we had issues with the
parents which happens quite often
parents will come in and yell at us for
their child not doing well and blame it
on the teacher so we tend to gossip
about that biggest pet peeve I would say
is students coming to my classroom at
lunchtime I mean just like blatant lying
with the little ones it's probably when
they just tap you constantly and they're
trying to get your attention like hi hi
hi I just needed my time to myself
that's a really really difficult because
you want to be nice you want to answer
questions but we need a little break too
plagiarism is a huge pet peeve because
it's incredibly easy to catch yet it is
so rampant another annoying thing that
students do is when they think they know
the answer to something and I'll try to
explain something in science oh I know
already I know already and I can't even
explain it to the other kids I'm like
that
I'm glad you know but they don't know so
she you know I think a lot of students
are just trying their best they're
trying their best in a system that is in
many ways stacked against them so I'm
pretty forgiving when it comes to the
little annoyances have I ever had a
student come in visibly or otherwise
intoxicated I'm sure I mean depending on
a good attendance day there are a
hundred and ten students in this class
was an auditorium class so the odds are
that a few of them are intoxicated
pretty high no cuz preschoolers are too
young for that but we have had kids come
in who are like clearly on medicine like
they're sick and their parents end up
knocked up on dayquil I have never had
any students coming in toxicated I would
be shocked if they did I think maybe
they were intoxicated on their
prescription medications but not
anything outside of that I also
understand that the world is falling
apart and you need to cope with that
feeling of hopelessness that I think a
lot of us are feeling in varying degrees
so I'm not gonna begrudge a student for
coming in drunk or high to a class as
long as they aren't disruptive and they
aren't stopping other people from
enjoying or at least listening to what I
have to say how where am I have their
personal lives they tell you everything
as far as like the relationship be kind
of stuff yeah with college classes you
typically take breaks in the middle
because you teach like three to four
hour classes and in those thirty minutes
you you hear some stuff they tell you
about baby sister's baby brothers
they'll tell you if their mom is
pregnant before mom tells you you'll
hear oh my Mommy has a baby in her belly
I am super aware of my students gossip
and personal lives because they are loud
okay they talk about everything all the
time with no awareness of anybody around
them so I hear everything and I have dog
ears so I hear stuff that I did not want
to hear they talking about parties they
talk about getting drunk getting high
I've overheard a girl accidentally pee
on herself they forgot to wear deodorant
all kinds of fun stuff the worst way of
cheating would be trying to signal to
their friend across the room like
because I can clearly see it it's
terrible you're not gonna get away with
it just study there's no cheating in
preschool but preschoolers are sneaky
you might say something's not open for
them or something's closed and they'll
turn around and go to another teacher
and say oh can I have some more
watermelon or can I have some more
quesadilla and then when they say yes
you were turn around you're like I just
told them no everything I did was essay
based I can hear the groans on the other
side of the screen the worst thing I've
seen is I taught a class of six people
so six essays that's not a lot of essays
two of the essays invariably were almost
identical every single time like your
pool is so small there's such a degree
of like intellectual inbreeding
happening right here that of course I'm
gonna catch them and of course I'm gonna
tell them that I caught them and you're
almost disappointed in the lack of
creativity and it's also kind of
insulting to you personally it was like
you didn't think I would notice I don't
know what kind of apathy you're dealing
with outside of this classroom but I
really care I care too much to a lot of
degrees I would say a good way of
cheating would probably be this is bad I
shouldn't be telling you guys this so
take a paper put it on your chair and
close your legs so that when you come
you know you could look down at in there
close your legs and then I probably
won't notice that I love the joy that I
get from seeing kids absorb information
and that I can make science cool being a
woman of color it's super super
important to show that being represented
is important being a teacher in
preschool is almost like being a movie
star you walk into a room and they are
thrilled to see you there's their run to
you they hug you they kiss you it's just
they're very excited to see you and that
is the biggest joy in preschool I mean
it's kind of cliche to say but when you
you see that aha look in a student's
eyes like being able to distill an
abstract concept into just a couple
sentences and have them understand it
for the first time is euphoric it's what
we want it's what we live for it to a
degree it makes me miss teaching more
and more every day cool is everything
for now but it's gonna change just focus
on loving yourself do your homework
listen to your parents
when you get older you have to start
over again
[Music]